madame la ministre des comités et
associations de pêcheurs normands m'ont
saisi pour me faire part de leur vive
inquiétude concernant le carnage de la
pêche industrielle
je me fais ici leur porte parole depuis
le mois d'octobre deux chalutiers g en
battant pavillon lituanien et allemands
sont arrivés sur les côtes normandes
sous le vent colère et inquiétude chez
nos pêcheurs locaux du tréport à
cherbourg ses usines flottantes
pratiquer une pêche de masse à une
échelle industrielle
ils sont dans leur droit au vu des
articles 32 à 39 du traité de rome qui
prévoit effectivement que tous les états
et membre puisse jeter leurs filets dans
ses eaux
en vertu de la politique commune de
pêche cependant les systèmes
d'aspiration de ces chalutiers
monstrueux vie de la mère de 250 tonnes
de poissons en une seule journée soit le
tiers de la pêche d'un chalutier
normands en un an
ne laissant que des miettes aux artisans
pêcheurs normands qui s'astreignent à
une gestion raisonnée en petites unités
madame la ministre c'est sans doute un
avant goût de la pêche post break site
ces navires sont en train de détruire
temps l'économie locale liée à la pêche
que les écosystèmes maritimes
or l'objectif de leur robe bleue est
aussi de préserver la biodiversité
marine et de prévenir les conflits entre
états membres
en tant que parlementaire de la seconde
région de pêche européenne c'est ce
paradoxe qui me conduit à vous demander
d'agir vous siéger dans les instances de
l'union européenne qui peut modifier la
politique commune de pêche
que comptez vous faire pour arrêter ce
massacre il faut des règles strictes
pour éviter que cette catastrophe et des
conséquences irréversibles pour notre
pêche artisanale